y no cesa la polémica en francia en
torno al paseo vacunal el pasado jueves
la asamblea nacional aprobó la
proposición de ley que solo permitirá
entrar a espacios públicos a personas
con la pauta completa de vacunación
ahora deberá pasar al senado no exenta
de polémica entretanto este domingo el
portavoz del gobierno gabriela tal ha
defendido su implantación elegimos el
pase de salud y luego el pase de vacunas
y obtuvimos resultados después del
anuncio del pase de salud de este verano
12 millones de franceses fueron a
vacunarse después del anuncio del cambio
el pase de salud a un pase de vacunación
allí vimos una vez más un aumento de
personas que se vacunaron que recibieron
su refuerzo en el foro apple at al
defendió esta medida ante la
obligatoriedad de la vacuna porque
afirma en países como austria no ha sido
efectiva sus declaraciones llegan
después de que miles de personas
salieran el sábado a las calles de parís
en protesta por la medida las marchas
fueron convocadas por el candidato de
extrema derecha florián filippo conocido
por su postura a favor de la salida de
francia de la unión europea
es un ataque a nuestras libertades no
estoy vacunado se lo digo inmediatamente
son nuestras libertades macro no respeta
la constitución por lo que es muy grave
para mí
entre los manifestantes aún resonaban
las palabras de macrón a le parisien el
presidente dijo que tenía ganas de
fastidiar a los no vacunados y
es sumamente grave que un presidente
diga eso la población lo odia
pese a sus declaraciones y una ola de
contagios que rondan los 300.000 casos
diarios en el país macrón sigue siendo
primero en las encuestas